I guess tonight starred as penny on the
Big Bang Theory
for 12 seasons now you can see her in
the animated series Harley Quinn which
is streaming on DC Universe
please welcome I love this woman Kaley
Cuoco Kaley how are you it's so good to
see you
what are you wearing is that like a
peasant blouse what is that oh yes a
traditional 1800s nightgown that I have
been living in since quarantine oh you
look like one of the little women
someone appreciate that oh I appreciate
it yeah it's so funny I was downstairs
and I said I have to go upstairs and my
wife said why and I said I've got to go
talk to Kaley Cuoco and her nightgown
that did not go over well you see the
nightgown you know it's not exactly a
turn-on of a nightgown it's more of a
repellant you know the thing about that
is it's not like a nightie that is a
real Jew like Charles Dickens nightgown
you know that's what Scrooge wore when
he went to bed and got visited by the
ghosts I walked with a little fire lamp
at night when I and I hold this and I
have a hat I just really get into the
character of that so yeah you nailed it
on the head
thank you do you know that also I would
say the plus of that kind of night
whereas you can wear that out right oh
yes yes the only place I've worn it
because I feel like I can get away with
it is this grocery store called air one
okay so you know you can wear anything
at air one and you're automatically cool
there are hipsters at air one so you can
walk in in that and there doesn't even
have to be a pandemic
you can tell them you quote oh I wasn't
talking but I've worn this was I've been
wearing this for years of the airway
yeah sales of alcohol are through the
roof people are drinking more yeah
what about you are you drinking more I
feel like all I've done for the past six
weeks is eat
drink and pick up it's all I've
done I hope you have dogs or else you're
just doing it as a hobby yeah yeah hey
dude what why is kaley cuoco picking up
with the dog what are you doing
playing fire yeah yeah we've been
drinking an excessive amount I really
have to tell you my husband is like a
really great book he's not a bartender
but he makes up all these drinks for me
and he we have a full bar and it's it's
been um we've we've formed problems at
this way
well first question what are you
drinking okay so my favorite drink is an
old fashioned but Carl my husband's name
is Carl he has created the Carl fashion
which involves scotch getting to my
belly scotch and it is so delightful
fresh orange but it's really important
to get the right glass and the right
measurement so it's perfect if we've had
a lot of those okay what time of day do
you start that's my second question and
this is important well you know I don't
want to be tacky I'll start the minute
we hang up this interview
okay well people think this is happening
at 11 o'clock at night I'm gonna tell
them now it is right now because we're
pre taping this it is 11:30 8:00 in the
morning I don't start before noon that's
just ridiculous right start at noon
you'll start okay good and how many of
these would you have I'm not sure they
go down really really really easily and
then all of a sudden I'm asleep and I
wake up and we do it all over again
hey and you're already dressed for bed
so you're all set you know Conan I've
been living as if no one will ever see
me again
really yes just the end of the food and
that hanging out it's like not really
doing in my hair makeup like I'm just
kind of I'm just kind of living like I
feel like I'm never going back to work
again it's very straight even doing this
with you I feel like you're the only one
that seen me which is not gonna be face
you should just keep me on in the corner
okay put me in the corner and you and
your husband can pass me and I'll be
like
it's really creepy it's one of the
creepier things I've suggested okay
Haley are ya are you doing yeah yeah
well okay I have to admit I'm doing that
a little bit too I'll eat things now
that I would never eat normally and I
have this feeling like it doesn't matter
what happens to me now it's weird it's
almost like like okay you can understand
this I'm eating as if I'm at craft
service so anyone that's you know craft
service obviously people know when
you're shooting the people that take
care of you and feed you but it's food
you would never have in your house right
anytime you're doing anything in show
business there's a table and it's filled
with all the stuff that no health
conscious person there's always like a
nod to others a little bowl of
vegetables yeah but then there's
goldfish crackers pound cake Nutter
butters
he's Nutter Butter in everything it's
it's ridiculous and when this all
started we all went crazy right we were
taking everything off the shelves
freaking out I mean I have so many years
it's like as if I had kids the stuff
that would go in their lunchbox we
didn't even have kids yeah weird fruit
roll-ups who does that
yeah those are good though those can
also be used as crude tools you know I
mean you can find things with meth I'm
curious because you mentioned your
husband Karl I know that you two have
been together two years right we've been
together for four years married for -
almost years yes okay married for two
years but until this quarantine you do
know yeah we just my dog that was that
Karl yelling don't answer that those are
just a couple of lion we're all tiger
king doubt now we are I am we all do we
all do it's like a normal thing but no
Karl night we just officially moved in
together after four years of beans isn't
that crazy
well maybe it's good I mean maybe that's
kind of healthy like to ease your way in
you know I it's worked great for us I
mean everyone has a million opinions
about what we do right but they were
very just shocked we didn't
live together and but it's been great
and now we just moved in together during
the quarantine and I I like him oh
that's really good that's that's really
good to be married to someone to know
them for four years and to have been
married to them for two years and then
realized I like this person now let me
ask you a question yeah is over and the
quarantine is lifted he's out he's out
this is just for the quarantine right
now I'm gonna tell my wife that I mean
it's not that this is yeah I was just
talking to Kaley Cuoco in her nightgown
and yeah you're out the minute the
quarantine is over and her husband's out
and you do the math yeah why you know I
want to ask you something about your
husband
because he sounds like a very cool guy
Carl cook he's an equestrian but he's
also a like championship-level
gardener is that true yes so he even
says now he's graduated from gardening
to farming he's an amazing farmer he
grows all of our food
he actually this is a very interesting
fact about my very strange adorable
husband he is a an award-winning pumpkin
grower
I'm just letting that silence hang right
there
that's the end of the sentence you know
what the nice thing is there's no
audience so I can just let horrible it's
horrible no no I like it in this
situation because you went he's an
award-winning pumpkin grower
no but you know what I know something
about pumpkin growing because my uncle
my dad's brother was an award-winning
pumpkin grower out wife yes and he grew
pumpkins out in Sturbridge Massachusetts
and he knew how to make that make the
pumpkins and you haven't lived till
you've seen pumpkins get oh I am so
amazed that you even know anything about
this it is very serious business like
the cross-pollination and the whole
thing they have to meet they have to the
pumpkins have to mate yes and sometimes
if a pumpkin shy you have to give them a
lot of privacy and music helps but you
do pumpkins together and then these
pumpkins get competitive pumpkin growers
take it really seriously don't get to be
like you know like as heavy as a truck
Frank yes his his first attempt ended up
to be about a hundred pounds and I
actually I asked him to send me a photo
last night he was like it wasn't my best
year and I was like a hundred pound pump
yeah I mean this is these are the things
that that he does but he grows
everything was funny when this whole
quarantine started I was like oh my god
you got even get our produce and our
this and he's like babe we're gonna live
off the land and I'm like how long have
you wanted to say that we're gonna he
was a little while he was very excited
[Laughter]
actually do you can live in the pumpkin
you can hollow those things out that's
like three thousand square feet of
living space
in a park no they aren't really
shockingly huge and I asked him I said
how did you learn how to do that and he
said you too yeah you too pumpkin sex
you're gonna learn you can well there's
all kinds of sex stuff on YouTube there
is not just pumpkin stuff
what's yeah there's squat you can see
squash going at it you can see turnips
you can see arugula I've watched three
ways with with arugula and leeks
[Music]
we're also watching a ton of TV being at
home so are you watching all new stuff
are you catching up on any old stuff I
love everything I love new stuff I love
reality but Carl and I started the first
season of Cheers
oh never saw it never watched an episode
I would have never watched Cheers before
so this is so crazy
so when we start a Big Bang Theory
really early on 47 years ago they said
we don't want Leonard and Penny to be
Sam and Diane we don't want that to
happen and I never knew what that meant
like fans and press would say this might
be like yeah we don't want that to
happen and I'd be like who's Sam and I'm
like who are they talking about night
Google I have no clue and then I thought
wait maybe we do want that but I never
knew and apparently I didn't take the
time to check so now that I've wrapped
the show and it's over I decided now
would be a good time to understand what
that meant
so you started watching cheers and now
do you get what a Sam and Diane
relationship is well we're only in
episode 9 but I have a feeling I know
what happens before we started recording
the interview we were just chatting I
was saying compared to me you guys are
just kids just starting out I still
think of Big Bang Theory as that new
show and I still think you guys are
going places cuz I served in the Civil
War it's so funny to me that you didn't
watch cheers but of course you didn't
watch Cheers
and what you just said that's a huge
compliment to our show I feel that way
about shows too that are obviously no
longer I mean especially like friends
and and Frasier and Seinfeld I watch
them now and they feel so modern to me I
feel like this aired you're gonna have
this with BIGBANG you've already
experienced it but you're gonna have all
these people that stay connected to you
through that show and you're gonna be
passing in an airport and see it on in
the background and go like I they
PTSD but I don't really know what
happens you know just depend on the
hairstyle I'll know by the hairstyle
because your hairstyle changed so much
episode almost yes every 30 months it
was differently it was 12 years so it's
a lot of different hair a lot of
different gene sizes - let me tell you
so I could tell by the clothes and the
hair and it's it's really interesting
how that that's how it connects for me
well I've been on the air for 27 years
and I will tell you this my hair style
never changed it started out looking
like a French pastry and it still looks
like a French pastry and so I have I
can't tell it does it looks like a
really delicious like oh there's yours
there's Anna there's cream in hair
there's everything yeah I'm dying to
Gary podcast I'm just sorry I didn't
know where this was going
but sorry sorry and you know you - hey I
got a pumpkin roller on my hand so I'm
doing justifying all right I got I
really want to get on your podcast and I
was doing the podcast is just this again
I can't see you in the nightgown so but
which is a shame but you'll have the
visual now yeah that's some hot visual
don't get me wrong
you look great but when I heard Kaylee
is gonna be wearing a nightgown
I expect didn't expect this did you
neither did Carl Carl keeps hoping for
something else not happening
hey I want to ask you about Harley Quinn
let's talk about Harley Quinn for sex
yeah this is an animated series and I
love that you're occasionally you just
hear a dog objection one of my question
it's like it's your publicist we're not
talking about Harley Quinn unlike being
trapped in like a very narrow animated
character Harlequin is as crazy as she
is she's very relatable that's what I
honestly love about the show I mean
there'll be scenes where Harley is
literally out
lashing someone's throat while she's
texting it her she or she'll be like
killing someone and she's like ah I need
a latte like yeah very relatable and
weirdly grounded and I can't believe
some of the stuff were allowed to say I
don't even know if we're lab but we do
it and they've let us do it so I'm hope
I hope we do another season it's people
seem to really like it there's this
rumored relationships possible
relationship between Harley Quinn and
poison ivy and I just want to say I'm
all for that let me let me put it this
way Harley's gonna need some calamine
lotion okay that was the funny joke I
just thought about off the top of my
head the calamine the poison ivy get it
oh yeah I'm writing that down
I've never found anything I've said in
the last 10 years that I'm using that I
go hold on
so make sure I get the word out on that
season two of Harley Quinn is now
streaming on DC Universe yes and new
episodes are available every Friday and
also I want to mention this a look out
for the flight attendant coming soon to
HBO max
anything about want to say we have a few
more episodes left we're still helping
to get it out this year but you know
we're kind of in the same boat as
everybody else so right it's it's you
know it's it's so frustrating I just
want all that crew all the crews to go
back to work and get back in knows when
that's gonna happen
I don't know we're gonna get there we're
gonna get there in the meantime I'm
happy to come by and help Carl with the
pumpkin social distance six feet Carl
six feet from the pumpkin okay okay I'm
excited to look up some eggplant
pollination as well now that you
mentioned it that's not really
interesting no I'm very big into the
world of vegan porn sure you go ahead
yeah that's fine okay Kaylee thank you
so much for talking to me no you really
did lift my spirits you're a very I
always loved talking to your
a buoyant fun cool person to talk to I
mean you are absolutely awesome I love
talking you coming on your show you make
it so easy and I really look forward to
seeing you so thank you for having me
all right
and I look forward to seeing you at the
supermarket dressed like Scrooge you
won't be it's which is which is no but
which is no guys fantasy by the way it's
not really Bailey thank you very much
this is great and we'll see you later
bye